The greens are coming for you rhaenyra and for
your children you should leave Dragonstone at once
my name is
high tide I am a dragon rider like my mother and
father and you high tide won't be safe agreed to
assume will clever and heroes over the Dragonstone
if more is coming it's coming for all of us
agreed to reach to use up our Queen's throat
we cannot hide from it and suffer too much loss
not into your lover
do you think I just and they must
be answered with Fire and Blood
I just saw my daughter first time in years
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie house the
Dragon released a new deleted scene from episode
10 the finale so we'll break it all down there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs here HBO is also in the
middle of their first fan convention for Game of
Thrones I'll do videos for any big announcements
or anything big that they release for instance
kit Harrington is doing a big Jon Snow panel
people hoping that he reveals more information
about the Game of Thrones sequel for Jon Snow
that they're making be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos but the reason why we have this
deleted scene is from the Blu-ray this way it
has the HBO Max tag at the end of this we'll
probably get some more deleted scenes when they
release the Blu-ray officially in a couple weeks
so I'll do more videos for those when they're
released this deleted scene takes place much
earlier in the episode after rainey's has come
to Dragonstone on her Dragon melees to warn
rhaenyra and Daemon about the greens naming aegon
second king during episode nine in the dragon pit
plane to kill her her entire family all of her
children anyone that's part of her side of the
family like the blacks basically to prevent any
other claims to the Iron Throne it was a very
common practice for royal families to do things
like that basically kill anyone out else that
could potentially challenge the succession and in
the map table room while she's revealing all this
she basically tells renera get the hell out of
here get off a Dragonstone with your family while
there's still time renera goes into early labor
with her and Daemon's daughter visenya and while
she's in labor because you can hear her screams
of pain in the beginning of this deleted scene
clip Daemon is with the black Council or what will
become the black council renira's version of the
small Council trying to do everything he can to
ignore reniro's screams of pain everyone around
him is kind of looking at each other like what are
we gonna do about this like we're near screaming
in the background we can barely concentrate
don't you want to go help her and he's just
doing everything he can to try and ignore it and
while that's happening rhaenys goes immediately to
Baela her granddaughter who'd she'd been fostering
for the past six years in the time Jump between
episode 7 and episode 8. remember she kept Baela
with her on high tide that whole time baela's twin
sister rhaena has stayed on Dragonstone with her
father Daemon in Rainier's family she tells Baela
the exact same thing she told renera time to get
the hell out of Dodge war is coming and as she
explains she just can't stand to lose any more of
her family her loved ones she lost her daughter
laena who is baela and rhaena's mother everyone
but raniera and Daemon still think that laner
died too so she thinks that her son died as well
remember laner didn't want to have anything to do
with what was happening with the greens he didn't
want to even be part of this family he wanted to
weigh out and raniera needed more support from
someone like Daemon which is why they tried to
kill those two birds with one stone by faking his
death so that he could escape and do whatever he
wanted to live a free life I've already talked
about him potentially coming back in a later
season because this whole idea that another
Valerian who's supposed to be the bastard of
corlys velaryon surfaces they could just say that
Lenor is that bastard and he's pretending to be
someone else and also when she's talking to Bella
saying let's get out of here she also still thinks
that her husband corlys velaryon might still
die because he's been recuperating on the edge
of death for a long time when this is happening
later in the episode she does get word that he's
come back to consciousness but he's very weakly
he's still on the edge of death and she rushes
back to be with him and yell at him a lot she was
mostly pissed at the thought of her entire family
being gone but she's also mad at him for bailing
on the family right after laenor's perceived
death because immediately after laenor died if it
wasn't clear Corlys took off to the stepstones and
has basically been Waging War down there for
the past several years the only reason why he
stopped is because he almost died and was forced
to recuperate otherwise he'd still be down there
and because you got so little of the girls Baela
Rhaena even their mother Laena Velaryon and what
they were trying to do with this scene was show
you more of baela's personality because in the
Fire and Blood book that they're adapting for the
story it's written that both baela and Rhaena had
a strong desire to join rhaenyra's boys who they
were betrothed to jaserys and luceris on their
dragons when it came time to make preparations
for war go around the realm securing support
from the other great houses and even though
Bayla is meant to be a little more hardcore
than her sister is both the sisters are kind
of like this and they're meant to take after
their mother like their personality is meant
to be similar to their mother's Lena full of
fire to make another Targaryen metaphor and if it
wasn't clear by the events of episode 9 Laena got
all that from her mother rhaenys you literally
see her walking around here wearing her full
Targaryen armor even though we make all the jokes
about her being the queen who didn't burn them all
during episode 9 her big Power moved to crash the
creen's coronation literally and metaphorically
is also just part of her personality like to go
big like that when things get crazy the whole
idea through season one is they want to show
you her personality what she might have been
like if she had been Queen like she's the queen
Who Never Was had she been queen vs viserys all
the things that she does the way that she reacts
to situations seem like much more traditional of
what you would expect from a king or queen to do
as opposed to viserys who most of the maesters
in the books after this view is a relatively
weak King in like the grand scheme of things
viserys's whole thing is that he was coming off
the back of jaehaery's reign and Jaehaerys was a
peacetime king and the realm had experienced 50
plus years of prosperity so when viserys became
king he wanted to keep the good times rolling
so to speak so he did everything he could to
avoid any kind of conflict much to the detriment
of the future of the realm the way the maesters
record things later on in the timeline is that
he is the person who's directly responsible for
the actual cance of the dragons like the events
that led up to the dance of the dragons had he
been a stronger King made better decisions early
on none of that stuff would have happened even
though paddy considine's performance as viserys
was amazing like he did an amazing job as the
character but the idea is that the character
himself was a weak king during the version of
the episode we actually saw on screen we got a
little bit of Baela and rhaena like during the
big black council meeting when they're actually
making plans for war and jaecerys lucerys say
that they're going to hit on their dragons and
secure more support from the other lords we
should bear those messages dragons can fly faster
than ravens and they're more convincing send us
Baela and Rhaena stand next to them like we're
going to help too and that's basically all you
get Ryan Condall said that there are all kinds
of deleted scenes like there's so much footage
that they had to leave in The Cutting Room floor
of all the characters that they did dirty I feel
like Laena Velaryon like Baela and rhaena's mother
and Baela and Rhaena themselves got the short end
of the stick talking about the biggest deleted
scenes from earlier episodes they ended episode
5 with renera marrying laner Valerian and Lena let
Daemon know that she was interested in marrying
him now that he was available she also didn't
seem very sad about the death of his first wife
and then they just completely skip over all of
Daemon and laena's story after that in favor of
the epic time Jump at the beginning of episode
6 where everyone's first batch of kids are huge
it was meant to be about a 10-year time Jump
obviously there was a ton of stuff that they
skipped over for all the different storylines but
just for the Daemon and laena Storyline by itself
the biggest missing parts that they got rid of
was the story of how Daemon was actually able
to marry Elena because it was a whole bunch of
stabbing and killing that Daemon had to do before
that could take place when Lena expresses her
interest in Daemon and Daemon is amenable to it
like okay that sounds like a good idea let's do
that at that time Lena was already betrothed to
the son of the Sealord of braavos so Daemon's way
of fixing this wound up being very similar to the
way that rhaenyra helped laenor get out of their
marriage later in episode 7. like you could see
when they're taking stuff from some storylines
and giving the moments to other storylines so
after rhaenyra's wedding was over Daemon came
to driftmark and Corlys Velaryon was amenable
to a match between Daemon and his daughter like
he wanted to get his family as connected to the
Iron Throne as possible as connected to the royal
family as possible and what had happened over in
braavos is that the Sea Lord that he had made this
marriage pact with for his son and his daughter
had died and the Sea Lord's son had taken over and
squandered all of his money so Corliss didn't care
about braavos anymore but he couldn't break the
marriage pact without good cause so Daemon went
full Rogue Prince like he pulled very familiar
move where he comes to braavos and he goads
the sea Lord's son into a fight attacking
him and use it as an excuse to kill him
say it thus ending Lena's betrothal allowing them
to get married is also kind of similar to the way
that he dealt with his first marriage like oh
we'll just kill our problems away how do we get
you out of this betrothal why don't we just kill
the person you're betrothed to problem solved like
I said in a very Daemon kind of way so I think
that they decided to get rid of that moment with
Daemon and laena because it was so similar to
The Twist they were using for laena later on and
because they wanted such an epic jarring time Jump
to so much later in the timeline like that let's
just kind of hand wave over all this history here
and because of that there's also this other huge
deleted scene from Daemon laena's storyline where
laena claims vegar when she was much much younger
so here's the thing with that too there are also
a couple minor book changes that they had with
alicent and rhaenyra's character and some of the
younger characters as well they did the same thing
during the original Game of Thrones series where
they changed the ages of some of the characters
in the books originally Lena claimed vegar in 105
AC that's the same year that viserys's first wife
aemma arryn died in childbirth and that was the
end of episode 1 on the series but when we get
to episode 2 and we meet laena velaryon she's
like a very very young child clearly a long ways
off from claiming vegar they did the same thing
with rhaenyra and alicent on the show on the show
alicent is way older than rhaenyra and she's in
her late 20s when she gets remarried to viserys
on the show they made it seem like alicent was
like 14 15 when she got married to viserys but
Laena claimed vhagar when she was about 13
years old and if you're going by the show's
timeline that would have been some time between
the events of episode 4 and episode 5. like when
she shows up in episode 5 to renura's wedding and
she starts talking to Daemon she's a couple years
older she's old enough to actually start having
children and she's been writing vegar for a little
while already the main reason why they said they
didn't include her writing vhagar in the final
episodes was because they wanted aemond claiming
vegar at the end of episode 7 just a few episodes
right after that to feel like a much bigger
deal kind of the same reason why they didn't
include ladies stoneheart on the Game of Thrones
series because like right after that would have
happened they would have had the big Jon Snow
resurrection moment and catelyn's stark coming
back as lady stoneheart would have telegraphed
that too much like amid was always going to be
a much bigger character on the show in general
to them through all the seasons so they wanted
to focus more on setting his character up which
is another side effect of them brushing through
the story so fast but the whole idea heading into
season two is that the actual Dance of the Dragons
begins like I said though there'll be more Delia's
scenes when they release the Blu-ray in a couple
weeks it's actually coming out pretty soon so
I'll try to do videos for all that stuff when
it releases if there are any big questions or
anything you spot in the deleted scene that I
didn't talk about in the video just write them
below in the comments everyone click here for
my house of the dragon season 2 video and all
my episodes and click here for my house the
dragon alternate ending and deleted scenes
video there are a whole bunch more deleted
scenes thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!